hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the stanley
parable now
there's really not a lot to explain this
game if you've seen my channel before
you know the the end is never the end is
okay if you see my channel this is the
story of a man named stanley
stanley worked for a company in a big
building where he was
employee number 427 employee number
427's job was simple
he sat at his desk in room 427 and he
pushed buttons on the keyboard
orders came to him through a monitor at
his desk telling him what buttons to
push
how long to push them and in what order
this is what employee 427 did every day
of every month of every year and
although
others might have considered it soul
ending stanley relished every moment
that the orders came in
as though we have been made exactly for
this job
and stanley was happy
and then one day something very peculiar
happened
something that would forever change
stanley
something he would never quite forget he
had been at his desk for nearly an hour
when he realized that not one single
order
had arrived on the monitor for him to
follow no one had showed up to give him
instructions
call a meeting or even say hi
never in all his years of the company
had this happened
this complete isolation something was
very clearly wrong
shocked frozen solid stanley found
himself unable to move for the longest
time
but as he came to his wits and regained
his senses
he got up from his desk and stepped out
of his office
and here we are so if you remember
before that intro was actually quite
familiar
um it's the same one in the last one so
i know that there's
more to this game than there is before
so let's adventure out and see what it
is and remember this is a
narration-driven game
so i'm gonna be conversing with the
narrator more than i'm going to be
conversing with you guys
wow one of these co-workers were gone
what could it mean
what danny decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
huh no matter how hard stanley looked he
couldn't find a trace of his co-workers
absolutely not i can't find a trace of
my co-workers
thanks for the hint so i need to get to
a meeting room you say
now the question is and what you guys
need to decide in the comments below
do i do what he tells me do i speak
good english men or do i go on my own
now where is the meeting room hello nope
meeting room stanley went around
touching
every little thing in the office but it
didn't make a single difference
right did it advance the story in any
way hey
hey if i want to lay my hands on
everything in this office i'm damn well
sure gonna
all right fine i'm gonna move on but not
because you told me to
because i want to right all right
good the narrator's kind of a prick
but that's all right when stanley came
to a set of two open doors he entered
the door on his left
oh do i i remember this choice before
i will go to the right this would do the
correct way to the meeting room
stanley knew it perfectly well shut up
perhaps he wanted to stop by the
employee lounge first
just to admire it yes may we do got a
good employee lounge i think he'll do
that thank you very much
dick the car your name is dick from now
on
yes truly a room worth admiring it had
really been worth the detour after all
just to spend a few moments here in this
immaculate beautifully constructed room
yes
stanley simply stood here drinking it
all in
yes
can feel this room in my eyes okay
enough of
marveling this one time to move yes
really but eager to get back to business
stanley took the first open door on his
left on my left
on my left you say left
well that does look like it would send
me back to where i need to go
however i'm not entirely sure that's
what i want to do
i will see where is this danny was so
bad at following directions
it's incredible he wasn't fired years
ago wow
how about you shut up okay you big joke
i'm gonna see what all this is about
because this looks like the half-life
place
do i work in the sector c test labs
i think perhaps we've gotten off on the
wrong foot
i'm not your enemy really i'm not are
you i realize that investing your trust
in someone else can be difficult
but the fact is that the story has been
about nothing but
you all this time ah there's someone
you've been directing
really yes i was in the middle of
something do you have zero consideration
for others
are you that convinced that i want
something bad to happen to you
yes i don't know how to convince you of
this but
i really do want to help you to show you
something beautiful
no let me prove it let me prove that i'm
on your side
no chance all right
maybe maybe but i'm out of here if i
smell one thing
fishy don't you try to pull nothing on
me the wool does not go over these eyes
i'm just trying everything 2v3
oddly enough i can't jump anymore now
listen carefully this is important
is it stanley walked through the red
door
do i why
why should i go through the red door
answer me that
i'm gonna go through the blue door i
like blue bear and red anyway
perhaps you misunderstood stanley walked
through the red
door the red door you say red
the pen is blue the pet is blue
the goddamn pen is blue we're
communicating
fine go ahead stanley you want to know
so badly what's out there you want to
find out what lies at the end of this
road you've chosen well don't let me
stop you
yes i want to know
there's nothing here i haven't even
finished building this section of the
map
because you were never supposed to be
here in the first place uh-huh broken
rooms exposed developer textures
is this what you had wanted yep was it
worth ruining the entire story i'd
written out specifically for you
yep do you not think i put a lot of time
into that because i did maybe and in the
end it was all for nothing
because this is what you wanted to see
yep help me here stanley help elucidate
these strange and unknowable desires of
yours
what would have made this game better
what did you want to see
vehicles skill trees work with me you
give me absolutely nothing so far yeah
all those things tell you what
let me take a stab in the dark at a new
design and you can give me some feedback
okay there we go a third option
this already feels leaps ahead of where
we were before
go ahead stanley take it for a spin oh
oh but but now
but now i want to go through the left
door
like you told meet you oh but i want to
go in there
ah i want to go i want to go i want to
go i want to go here i want to go there
i want to go there oh
the toys is eeny meeny miny can i save
can i save yeah
i can i oh damn it i don't see any
specifics
i better go yes
i'm going to stop you there now tell me
about your experience with this new
version would you say that the game
benefited from allowing you more choices
feel free to be honest i'm looking for
some real critical feedback here
aha you see i knew i was onto something
where do these flashes of inspiration
come from how did i know the game needed
a third door
i don't know it's instinct mostly a
calling in your gut oh i really couldn't
say where the idea came from
i felt it in myself oh oh teach that
stanley oh don't even try
oh here based on the data from your
previous playthrough i've compiled a new
version
and to be perfectly candid i think i've
knocked it out of the park with this yay
whoa what the
hey wait a minute worldwide leaderboard
wow are those real statistics holy crap
that that's pretty awesome 21 percent uh
three players chose the blue door
only the worst three percent a player ah
ah ow what that's me
i'm ranked last well thanks dick i'm
going through the left door
f you fine
oh wait a minute would you say that
competitive leaderboard
helped you feel motivated to keep
walking through doors
again honest answers please no
you rank me lowest hey i nearly forgot
i've got a prototype of a new game i've
been working on
and now would be a lovely opportunity to
give it some play testing don't worry
you wouldn't mind taking a look at it
would you yeah let me boot it up
we're gonna play what are we doing whoa
in this game
the baby crawls left towards danger
you click the button to move him back to
the right and if he reaches the fire
you fail it's a very meaningful game all
about the desperation and tedium of
endlessly confronting the demands of
family life
i think the art world will really take
notice
but of course the message of the game
only becomes clear
once you've been playing it for about
four hours so why don't you give it four
hours of play
to make sure it's effective what do i do
to keep notes on your experience what do
i do
oh god no the baby oh god no
oh god oh oh this bastard oh
did you do it because you hate babies or
purely despite me
because if it's the latter well i don't
know what to do i don't know
i can't think of a single thing that
might improve the experience for me
i'm not even going to try i'm out i'm
out i'm done
you're out it's over it's over you're
playing your input was extremely
valuable oh hey since my game was so
awful
why don't we play someone else's game
just to ease the pain
let's see what do we have here
yes this seems like it'll work let's
give it a shot
will it oh god
hey what well stanley is this any better
way
at last the ones i can't jump always
desire i can't jump game i had
absolutely nothing to do i can't jump i
love minecraft
oh god stanley yeah will it ever be
enough oh it's so much enough i'm gonna
mod it i'm done making things for you
oh good from now on i will only create
to fulfill a greater artistic purpose
watch this stanley i'm going to build a
house
okay wow
wow yeah the clouds are actually moving
and then it's freaking minecraft
let's see what does it need i yes of
course
so just to finish it all off yes
it's i completely this standing wow
look at it gaze upon my work of art
i feel ashamed at your own inadequacy
but you've only seen it from the outside
you've only gotten half the experience
please step inside and make yourself
comfortable oh absolutely i will i ca
yeah and isn't it perfect it could only
be better if
wait that's it we must rebuild it
out of diamond or diamond everything
yeah yes yes yes come along stanley we
have to go mining oh
let's go mining playing
minecraft it looks deadly bearable
oh
looks like it's going to get a bit dark
have you brought a light no
maybe i don't know you tell me oh great
sky god
oh boy oh no no no no no this is far
more open-ended than i had in mind what
i'm looking for something more narrow
and linear oh wow something that makes
you feel utterly irrelevant
what this won't do at all one out of
five no
diamonds couldn't save this one oh do i
hear
oh i thought i heard a zomb
i really thought i heard one was there
really one down there
ah
yes i don't even know what this game is
but i love
it you trapped in a glass box
with no way out oh it's inspired
i couldn't have done it any better
myself what is this game even supposed
to be
i can't figure it out okay now i'm
curious let's go find out what the hell
this is no
yes yes i'm playing
boyle
it's a puzzle critical thinking stanley
yes
indeed
hey is that trying to say something are
you insinuating something
no actually you know what i think that's
plenty i really don't care much to see
you stumble through any
more of these games and i highly doubt
you're any wiser for the experience
which is why rather than continue to
waste my time i'm just going to leave
you here
you can pretend you've beaten the game
if it makes it any richer for you but as
for me
i've had enough for me so why don't you
get cozy in this room and if you have
any grand
revolutionary ideas for the perfect
video game you can just sit there and
let it ball up inside you for all
eternity
okay i need your advice okay i don't
need your ratings
okay and i certainly don't need the
validation of a man
whose job is to push buttons i think
i'll just go about my business
making meaningful cultural contributions
to the world
and perhaps every now and then i'll
think back to a man named stanley
who was objectively wrong in every
decision he ever made
the thought won't last long goodbye
stanley
goodbye with your work and i sincerely
hope that everyone lives happily ever
after oh indeed
all right so that was the stanley
parable it's over now i guess no
i'm going to play more of this it's so
cool it's our girl i have choices
ah playing minecraft on a mid-portal
okay so there'll be more of this coming
so
thank you all so much for watching click
the invitation for more videos that i've
done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye
oh